rencontre entre
matisse mort quand il avait 8
manquaient toujours
5 buffle perdent leurs frères la veille
de ses 9 ans alors qu'ils tentent de
faire leur deuil le père et la mère
disparaisse eux aussi ils se retrouvent
livrés à eux mêmes face aux lions c'est
comment ses cinq enfants en fait arriva
à essayer de s'en sortir suite à ces
différents drames comme les fables de la
fontaine comme ionesco en fait la
métaphore animalière pour pouvoir parler
mieux des humains
elle
[Musique]
oh
c'est un projet des bougies
mais
en
fait les lions représente vraiment la
société les dangers de la société les
coups durs aussi et surtout les tous les
dangers sur lesquels les bus doivent
faire face et comment en fait il sait
aussi se met on semble vraiment en
troupeau pour pouvoir résister face à
selongey écrite par pas omis euros en
2008 la pièce pioche dans les genres du
polar et du drame familial la mise en
scène épurée poétique est un hybride
entre fable et réalisme là vraiment on
est dans une forme qui déplace
complètement théâtre on est dans une
fable c'est un compte il ya très peu de
dialogues donnent à voir trois dans la
pièce le reste est vraiment que des
personnages qui essaie de raconter ou
passés ou présents ce qui leur est
arrivé essayer de vivre avec ça c'est
vraiment le souvenir c'est comment il
arrive à vivre avec ce souvenir ses
souvenirs difficiles alors c'est pas
dénué d'humour c'est une pièce qui est
assez noir sur pas mal de choses mais il
ya quand même une vie extraordinaire et
comme j'ai un travail de metteur en
scène très corporelle c'est quasiment
chorégraphique c'est quasiment dans ces
cinq personnages pour cinq points de vue
différents sur la famille et une morale
à retenir la jungle s'affrontent
difficilement sens entre pont
[Musique]